[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
9 décembre 2021 à Londres un tribunal
symbolique composé d'experts et de
juristes a rendu un verdict historique
après plusieurs semaines d'audition de
témoin pour les jurés le doute n'est
plus permis
un génocide a bien lieu en ce moment
même contre les ouigo
la réaction de la Chine tombe
immédiatement
le soi-disant verdict d'une telle
machine à produire des mensonges ni rien
d'autre qu'une farce politique mise en
scène par une poignée d'individus
méprisable
quelques semaines plus tôt dès le début
du procès Pékin avait donné le ton
la Chine a raison sur un point le
tribunal oui gourde Londres n'a aucune
compétence juridique
mais son impact n'en est pas moins
considérable
le verdict fait le tour du monde
et surtout convaincre des Parlement de
valider officiellement le risque de
génocide
comme à Paris le 20 janvier 2022 il
n'est pas besoin de convoquer l'image du
charnier de la chambre à gaz ou de la
machette pour établir la réalité d'un
génocide le tribunal citoyen de Londres
a démontré en décembre dernier que la
politique du gouvernement chinois relève
de la convention de 48 sur le génocide
alors je rêve aujourd'hui d'une
assemblée unanime où chacun d'entre nous
en votant cette résolution en
reconnaissance au génocide face
raisonner jusqu'aux xinja jusqu'en Chine
la voie de l'humanisme et de
l'universalisme des droits humains merci
agir pour les 8 gours c'est donc voter
en faveur de cette résolution ce que
fera naturellement le groupe agir
ensemble notre groupe sera bien
évidemment en faveur de cette
proposition de résolution la priorité
est d'agir de la façon la plus unanime
pour faire de ce génocide et bien sûr
nous serons complètement à vos côtés la
majorité se prononcera donc en faveur de
cette proposition
de 75 votants 170 s'exprimer pour 169
contre 1 la proposition est donc adoptée
je pense que nous avons une opportunité
exceptionnelle d'au moins faire quelque
chose de reconnaître à temps l'existence
de ce génocide qui puisse être empêché
ou pas parce que ce génocide se déroule
sous nos yeux lentement
donc c'est une occasion historique
d'agir et si rien n'est fait ce sera une
faute historique
Luxembourg
un génocide en cours
comment en est-on arrivé là
d'où vient cette accusation
l'un des premiers à en avoir parlé au
plus haut niveau c'est lui en 2019
Mike Pompeo était le secrétaire d'État
du président Trump
pour attaquer cette Chine devenue une
rivale il va appuyer là où ça fait mal
elle China
c'est plus compliqué que ça reprenons
les choses par le début
[Musique]
le Cink Yang c'est cette province
chinoise à l'extrême ouest du pays la
plus grande de toute la Chine elle
regorge de ressources naturelles
gaz pétrole charbon et elle est la porte
d'entrée pour les nouvelles routes de la
soie vers l'Occident elle est peuplée
pour moitié de minorité musulmanes
turcophone
principalement des Ouigours
officiellement ils sont 12 millions
pendant des années personne ne
s'intéressait vraiment à eux
Jean c'est quelque chose
sur cette photo j'ai 25 ans nous sommes
à la fin des années 1990
je travaille pour la presse écrite et je
découvre le King
la région est en ébullition les ouigos
ont vu la récente chute de l'Union
soviétique et la création de nouveaux
pays en Asie centrale voisine
Pékin comprend le danger et réprime
chaque manifestation dans le sang
l'opposition me parle d'avortement
forcée et de stérilisation
me remets des photos à peine soutenable
j'ai du mal à croire à toutes ces
horreurs
alors j'y retourne
pour enquêter encore
[Musique]
sur une vingtaine d'années je vois
l'arrivée massive des collants chinois
je vois les destructions méthodiques des
quartiers entiers construits du temps de
Marco Polo
l'effacement progressif d'une culture
millénaire
[Rires]
la tension monte
Pékin est obligé d'envoyer toujours plus
de militaires sur place
comme ici en 2014 à cash gare l'une des
plus grosses villes à majorité ouigo
à l'époque on alerte déjà sur les
emprisonnements de masse de jeunes qui
disparaissent du jour au lendemain
il serait envoyé dans des prisons vers
le désert
[Musique]
j'y étais allé
des kilomètres de grillage et de
barbelés au milieu de nulle part
et soudain un camp de travail
et c'est des prisonniers qui ont fait
des crimes c'est quoi
les détenus sont en uniforme bleu et
orange
[Musique]
bleu et orange les couleurs
réglementaires des tenues des
prisonniers et des victimes du travail
forcé
sur ces photos satellites on reconnaît
parfaitement les serres agricoles sur la
droite et sur la gauche ce que je ne
pouvais voir de la route un vaste
complexe carcéral entouré de murs avec
des miradors
j'ai tourné ces images en avril 2014
et exactement même moment chez Jim ping
lance secrètement une nouvelle campagne
de mise au pas du kingerang
Boris parvenir les arrestations doivent
se multiplier de manière industrielle
et pour enfermer tous ces prisonniers
il faut de la place
beaucoup de place
dans les mois qui suivent la prison que
j'avais filmé double rat de volume
partout dans la province
Pékin construit des centres de détention
des milliers
tous ces points sur la carte du King
ce serait des sites d'internement
les jaunes pour les camps de rééducation
les rouges pour les prisons
et les Verts pour les camps de travail
en tout il y en aurait près de 400
ça c'est ce que prétendre des experts
internationaux d'images satellites
Pékin crée au complot répète qu'il n'y a
pas de camp ou alors qu'il s'agit juste
de centres de formation professionnelle
affirmation qu'il faut croire sur parole
puisque la région est devenue
inaccessible
quasiment inaccessible
fin 2021 un jeune youtuber chinois
diffuse une vidéo accablante pour le
régime
il se fait appeler Gwen
son idée était simple
reprendre les points GPS des experts en
satellites et aller sur place aux
cinquante pour voir ce qui s'y trouve
pas dans plusieurs jours il est allé
d'un site à un autre et à voler des
images de ses prisons qui officiellement
n'existent pas
[Musique]
petit à petit l'épreuve s'accumulent
contre la Chine
des rapports d'organisation humanitaires
sont publiées
des survivants commencent à témoigner
c'est suffisant pour que des
gouvernements se mettent à accuser la
Chine de génocide
en Europe plusieurs capitales suivent le
mouvement
Pékin ne compte pas se laisser faire et
menace tous ceux qui au soutenir les
Ouigours y compris des parlementaires
Samuel cogoletti est député vert à
l'Assemblée belge
il a été le premier élu au monde à faire
voter la reconnaissance du risque de
génocide
le jour même où nous avons déposé le
texte et donc cette proposition de
reconnaissance du génocide du Gour ici
au Parlement à Bruxelles
l'ambassade de Chine en Belgique
répondait immédiatement envoyer une
lettre à la présidente de l'Assemblée de
l'Assemblée législative pour lui
demander de ne pas discuter de ne pas
mettre ce texte à l'agenda ce qui est
excessivement rare moi c'est la première
fois que je voyais
un État tiers qui se permettait quelque
part une ingérence dans les affaires
internes d'un parlement d'un pays
démocratique comme la Belgique qui se
permettait de dire attention de discuter
pas de ce sujet
[Musique]
pour être franc l'agressivité du régime
chinois ne m'étonne pas
je sais que la question du xyang est
sensible pour Pékin très sensible
c'est pour cela que je prends toutes les
précautions possibles pour protéger mes
informations
certains encore plus que d'autres
c'est le cas de celui que je vais voir
maintenant
c'est un officier de la police
criminelle chinoise
il a été en poste dans la région
en 2020 il a fait défections et ses
réfugiés en Allemagne il a longtemps
hésité avant de me recevoir
comme dans un film d'espionnage
le lieu du rendez-vous doit être tenu
secret et son anonymat soigneusement
préservé
il sait qu'à terme les services chinois
finiront par découvrir qui il est et se
lanceront à sa poursuite
mais il veut encore se laisser quelques
jours quelques semaines de répit avant
de les affronter
les camps il les a vu les prisonniers il
les a vu également
on enferme des innocents quand je suis
arrivé en poste au cimetière j'ai
entendu qu'il y avait 900 000
prisonniers dans tous les villages il y
a des camps de concentration avec leur
politique de répression ils enferment
tout le monde on les tortures avec de
l'eau glacée et d'autres techniques plus
atroces jusqu'à ce qu'ils parlent ça
dépend de la résistance des prisonniers
face à la souffrance
pour obtenir plus de résultats en
torture encore plus tous les moyens sont
bons notamment avec des matraques
ce sont des pratiques très fréquentes au
signe qui engagent
ces séances de torture des victimes
étaient venues les décrire devant
l'Assemblée d'experts à Londres
[Musique]
la chaise du tigre c'est comme crucifier
quelqu'un
c'est pour mettre une pression maximale
sur les prisonniers
qui n'obéissent pas les policiers de
frappes
étaient courantes dans d'autres
provinces de Chine maintenant c'est
terminé mais pas aussi qui engue là-bas
les autorités nous laissent faire ce que
l'on veut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les actes de torture aux ferait plus
guère de doute
pour autant est suffisant pour qualifier
le drame ouigo de génocide
selon la convention des Nations Unies la
réponse est non
[Musique]
pour qu'il y ait génocide il faut
prouver l'intention de détruire tout ou
partie d'un groupe ethnique ou religieux
soit par des meurtres de masse des
attentes graves à l'intégrité physique
ou mentale la soumission à des
conditions d'existence entraînant la
mort le transfert forcer d'enfants du
groupe à un autre groupe
l'imposition de mesure visant à entraver
les naissances
nous faisons face à un nouveau type
d'atrocités nous n'avons pas le
classique meurtre de masse avec des
zones entières recouvertes de cadavres
comme au Rwanda ou en Bosnie nous
n'avons pas de charnier à découvrir nous
nous trouvons face au cinquième critères
de la Convention des Nations Unies avec
les entraves aux naissances il n'existe
pas de précédent c'est tout aussi valide
tout aussi problématique c'est tout
autant une entrave à la vie c'est tué en
empêchant des centaines de milliers si
ce n'est des millions de vie à venir à
travers les stérilisations les pauses
forcées de stérilet et les opérations et
nous disposons de preuves documentées ce
qui est essentiel
le chercheur allemand s'appuie sur des
centaines de rapports officiels qu'il a
exhumé sur des sites internet
gouvernementaux chinois
comme ces statistiques sur le nombre de
femmes stérilisées
la courbe orange c'est celle du xink
elle explose alors que la bleue celle de
la Chine s'effondre
l'objectif de Pékin devient évident en
réduisant les naissances les Ouigours
seront bientôt trop minoritaires pour
réclamer leur indépendance
dans les documents officiels de Sécurité
d'État les directives sont claires
elle nous indique comment nous devons
lutter contre le séparatisme au
cynthiang pour que ça ne devienne pas la
Tchétchénie
[Musique]
nous disposons de témoignages de femmes
qui ont été stérilisés ou de médecins
ouigo qui disent avoir été forcé de
pratiquer des opérations
étaient jetées dans des bus par la
police chinoise pour être emmené dans
des cliniques sous haute sécurité
et qu'elles y ont été stérilisés en fait
nous avons beaucoup de preuves
cette femme s'appelle
elle a été infirmière pendant des années
avant de fuir en Turquie
face au tribunal à Londres elle a aussi
brisé le silence sur les avortements
forcés
quelques jours plus tard les autorités
chinoises ont diffusé sur Internet une
vidéo on y voit de femmes qui racontent
qu'elle ment il s'agit de sa fille et de
sa sœur
sa fille elle n'a jamais réussi à la
faire sortir de chez
c'est la première fois qu'elle la revoit
en 5 ans
tous les réfugiés qui s'expriment
publiquement doivent s'attendre à
recevoir ce genre de vidéo
le principe est simple et efficace
attention votre parole met en danger
votre famille restez au pays
ce chantage ne sert pas qu'à faire taire
les opposants il peut les forcer à jouer
les informateurs
la séquence qui suit est rare
de ouigo sont en appel vidéo
celui qui apparaît en grand sur l'écran
du téléphone via aux cinquième
il appelle son frère almat qui s'est
installé au Japon
[Musique]
comme ça
avant de répondre l'agent chinois se
tourne vers le frère et fait bien
comprendre almat qu'il le tient en son
pouvoir
[Musique]
Allemagne recevra d'autres appels du
policier
il refusera de collaborer
[Musique]
toutes ces intimidations chinoises
c'est à cause d'elle que si peu de ouigo
accepte de témoigner
la diaspora a compris qu'elle devait
relever ce défi celui de l'information
mitter illicute est une militante du
ouigo transitionnal justice database une
plateforme qui recense les disparitions
partout dans le monde
comme ici à Istanbul
[Musique]
c'est notamment sur son travail que
c'est appuyé le tribunal de Londres
quelques mois plus tôt
ne s'est intéressé que très peu aux
problèmes de son peuple tout a changé
quand la Chine a attaqué sa famille
rester en
je restais dans ma petite bulle assez
naïve
j'étais beaucoup moins en lien avec la
communauté Ouigours
je vivais ma propre vie d'étudiante à
l'université
à peine attention à ce qui pouvait bien
se passer dans ma patrie
jusqu'à ce que j'appelle ma grand-mère
en 2017
la dernière chose qu'elle m'a dit c'est
ne m'appelle plus
elle a ajouté la situation se complique
ne nous appelle plus on te recontactera
quand ça ira mieux
bien sûr ça n'est jamais arrivé
le déclic a été radical dans la foulée
mettèrent décidé de changer de vie et de
mettre au service des victimes
après tout je suis moi-même une wiggour
et une victime j'ai de la famille dans
les camps
j'ai des proches qui ont été emprisonnés
relâchés qui en sont sortis handicapés
être un membre de leur famille ça
m'oblige à faire quelque chose
le devoir de rendre compte des histoires
les plus tragiques comme celle de ces
deux hommes
il y a quelques années ils ont fui la
Chine pour trouver refuge en Turquie
puis ils ont tenté de faire venir leur
famille
trop tard
celle-ci avait été jetée en prison
[Musique]
en langue chinoise c'est l'un des
enfants disparait
[Musique]
se trouve dans la même situation
sa femme a été envoyée dans un camp et
ses trois enfants dans un orphelinat
[Musique]
arracher les enfants à leurs parents
quand ils sont tout petits et leur faire
oublier jusqu'à leur langue et leur
culture
personnage c'est l'une des méthodes de
Pékin pour résoudre dans un futur proche
la question ouigo
je pense que le plan sur les 10 à 20 ans
à venir est une forte assimilation et
une réduction drastique de leur vie
spirituelle de leur particularisme
linguistique et culturel sauf pour tout
ce qui est folklorique il les laisseront
chanter danser
[Musique]
leur valeur profonde le cœur de leur
identité ethnique sont en train d'être
érodées et détruits tout spécialement
pour les jeunes générations
[Musique]
douleur émotion il arrive un moment où
les mots ne suffisent plus pour décrire
le pire
mes terres voir imaginez le réel à
défaut de le vivre
idrissaïa c'est un jeune oui Gourg
validé il vient d'ouvrir en plein cœur
d'Istanbul le musée du génocide ouigo
afin de tuer
la visite débute par la terrible chambre
noire
celle où les prisonniers ouigo subissent
les interrogatoires
[Musique]
Idriss est arrivé en Turquie il y a 10
ans ses parents sont restés auxiliang
depuis 2017 il n'a plus aucune nouvelle
d'eux il ne sait même pas s'ils sont
toujours en vie
ce musée c'est son idée
il veut provoquer le visiteur le choqué
pour qu'il s'interroge et réagissent
[Musique]
certains disent que c'est un génocide
lent
c'est exactement ça
génocide depuis le début de cette
enquête ce mot revient sans cesse il en
deviendrait presque banal
pourtant même lent il garde un objectif
effroyable
éradiquer définitivement un peuple
[Musique]
est de retour chez ses parents dans une
petite ville du sud de la Norvège c'est
aussi pour eux qu'elle se bat
[Musique]
tre
histoire de cette famille est tristement
banale pour échapper aux pressions
chinoises elle a dû fuir les
grands-parents eux n'ont pas pu les
suivre
[Musique]
Oslo
capitale de la Norvège
la vie est si paisible
ce samedi matin d'avril
les promeneurs profitent en famille des
premiers rayons du soleil
comment croire que l'enfer existe quand
on vit dans un monde de paix et
d'équilibre
mais terre se dirige vers les locaux de
l'association pour laquelle elle
travaille
la petite équipe attend
ils doivent appeler un homme
un oui Gour il s'appelle sadirdine
évite au Kazakhstan avec ses trois
enfants sa femme était partie toute
seule en Chine en 2016 pour un voyage
d'une semaine
elle n'est jamais revenue
la
dernière que nous avons parlé à ce
témoin c'était en décembre 2019 et il
nous a dit que sa femme avait disparu
depuis des années
mais après que nous avons diffusé son
témoignage sur notre chaîne YouTube en
2019 sa femme a soudainement repris
contact avec lui trois jours plus tard
elle a été tournée au téléphone portable
aux Cink Yang dans une voiture
loin des regards
tout ne pas se faire prendre par les
Chinois
a suivi son conseil il a patienté
mais son épouse reste introuvable
alors il a compris qu'il devait agir
terminé le silence à partir de
maintenant il fera tout pour que le
monde entier sache que la Chine a
détruit une famille innocente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les mois ont passé la situation est
restée la même c'est-à-dire digne ne
voit plus qu'une option possible allez
en Chine pour enlever sa femme
[Musique]
proche de la frontière avec le
Kirghizistan
sur une carte ça paraît tout près
tellement près
500 km
500 petits kilomètres
une journée de route
voilà ce qui sépare c'est à dire digne
de son épouse
grâce à
il s'est désormais exactement où elle se
trouve
il suffirait d'obtenir un visage d'aller
la chercher la sauver
les Chinois il sera les convaincre quand
il sera sur place devant eux il en est
persuadé
c'est si simple dit comme ça
alors il a pris la voiture ses enfants
et à rouler du Kazakhstan où il vit
jusqu'au montagne
[Musique]
je peux retrouver ma femme
et comme j'y vais avec mes enfants
les autorités chinoises vont être
obligées de lui rendre son passeport
parce que selon le droit international
on ne peut pas séparer les enfants de
leur mère
[Musique]
pour témoigner en faveur de son père
qui avait été jeté en prison
mais dès qu'elle a franchi la frontière
entre le Kazakhstan et la Chine
elle a été piégée
et elle n'a toujours pas d'autorisation
de rentrer chez nous
[Musique]
il y avait bien longtemps que la petite
famille n'avait pas été aussi heureuse
l'espoir de retrouver cette épouse cette
mère si longtemps disparue ressurgit
[Musique]
et pourquoi pas pour les 9 ans de la
petite Fatima
[Musique]
son anniversaire est dans une dizaine de
jours
[Musique]
mais pour cela il faut traverser ces
sommets enneigé ce qui entourent
bichette
la capitale du Kirghizistan
avant de faire sa demande de visa
sadiardine veut savoir quelle est la
situation en terre guise
est-ce que la frontière avec la Chine
est ouverte
est-ce que comme au Kazakhstan les
militants Ouigours sont traqués parfois
arrêtés remis aux autorités chinoises
toutes ces réponses
un homme peut les lui donner
[Musique]
est une personnalité qui compte parmi la
diaspora locale
il s'appelle Rosie Mohamed et représente
le Congrès mondial ouigo au Kia existant
que j'en ai marre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le projet familial doit être abandonné
c'est-à-dire ne prendra pas le risque de
perdre ses enfants ou d'être lui-même
arrêté
les condamnations diplomatiques et les
pressions médiatiques n'ont rien changé
à l'attitude de la Chine le pays
continue de violer ouvertement les
droits les plus basiques des Ouigours et
des autres minorités turcophones du
cimetière
les gouvernements ne sont en fait pas
très intéressés par les violations des
droits de l'homme parce que ce n'est pas
ce qui les fera relire les gouvernements
veulent être réélus ils ont besoin
d'avoir une bonne économie des emplois
entre autres choses et pour cela ils ont
souvent besoin de la Chine je ne vois
pas l'attitude qui serait nécessaire
pour remplir l'obligation qu'on les
gouvernements selon la convention de
1948 je ne le vois pas
[Musique]
le drame dugsinkyang joue un bien
mauvais tour aux grandes démocraties
américaines et européennes
il les force à révéler un visage peu
reluisant
celui d'État prêt à fermer les yeux sur
le pire des crimes au nom d'intérêts
économiques et politiques
en décembre 2021 le président du
tribunal de Londres sort Geoffrey Nice
n'avait pas caché son amertume
[Musique]
la chose juste est de faire quelque
chose de le dire haut et fort et de dire
ça c'est mal et de sanctionner les
violations des droits de l'homme
n'importe où dans le monde y compris en
Chine la chose juste est de dire que ce
travail forcé nous ne pouvons pas en
importer la production simplement parce
que c'est mal il y aura-t-il un effet
positif ou pas qui c'est possible faire
les choses juste à souvent des effets
positifs à long terme
voilà donc tout ce que l'on a proposé au
ouigo attendez patientez ça finira par
aller mieux
sauf que l'on parle de génocide
face à la démission de la communauté
internationale
mettait pourraient tout arrêter
mais elle s'y refuse
je vais faire du mieux que je peux parce
qu'étant Ouigours moi-même je me sens
moralement obligé de faire ma part
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que je vais continuer et passer
ma vie à me battre pour la liberté de
mon peuple
et surtout
continuez de donner un visage à chacune
des victimes de la répression chinoise
pour que nul ne puisse prétendre un jour
que l'on ne savait pas que ça n'existait
pas
en 1996 un wego m'avait dit si rien ne
change nous allons disparaître et le
pire c'est que personne n'y prêtera
attention
ce documentaire c'est le minimum que je
pouvais faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]